what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting
to a clip that was sent to me on my
instagram this guy said that he is
shocked
that it doesn't have a hundred thousand
views so i'm just really excited to see
if it's any good or not
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel
um as you guys know i'm trying to hit 20
000 subscribers this month
each and every one of you help while
you're at it ring that notification
bell by the way this video is titled um
are religious women better
i'm a little nervous hey what's going on
fellas i just want to say
thanks for the group i really appreciate
you guys spreading the knowledge
because i'm tired of seeing uh males
getting beta mailed out there
like it's tough to see after you take
the red pill so yeah i just want to say
thank you so
my question is yeah i've been going to
church my whole life
so i wanted to get you guys opinion on
christian woman
when i was blue pill i thought all the
girls in church were different
but after taking the red pill i
completely my eyes were completely open
and i started to realize all the beta
bucks in the church and
how church women are really no different
than any other woman and they're still
hyper gamers and
to be honest most of them are [ __ ] like
i found most of the [ __ ] in church
christian girls are different they are
different in that
they're they're they're slutting for
jesus they're slutting for christ right
like that's the that's what they do it
under listen man church girls
they're they're the they're as every
hypergamous as any other girl out there
and they just do it under the guise of
something else
this is what irritates me um
okay i did 12 years at catholic school i
was baptized to be
christian like a year ago so maybe i'm a
little bit biased but
every single girl that i know that
waited until they were married
like i have one friend that had her
first kiss on her wedding day i have
another
friend that was a virgin tell she got
married at 24 which is
very rare they all were very religious
like went to church every day i'm not
saying they weren't like hypergamous
like
in terms of like that
they wanted um
like the same things other girls want
i'm sure like
but kinda i'm pretty sure their husbands
were virgins
too so it would go against some of the
things they say like
they want like a guy that's like been
with a bunch of other guys
um let me just continue well they also
spell like the lyrics and the notoriety
of their idealist uh storytelling i mean
i'm just gonna say this again look i
mean if you believe that a man in the
sky in a talking stake and a dude you
know part of the seas with two slabs of
stone
you know like the story that you want to
go into i've got a whole library of
disney movies my daughter's got on dvd i
could show you as well
um you know at the end of the day women
are women there's no good women there's
no bad women there's just women
so i just got it okay so you're telling
me like this is what irritates me
you're telling me that um what's that
girl's name that's lana ray
and my friend that had her first kiss on
her wedding day are no different
like tana moja let me know if i'm
misconstruing the argument at all
go ahead go ahead yeah i got something
out here it just came to me but
i can imagine in 2018 the churches today
are attracting a lot of [ __ ]
uh basically women who want to kind of
well they hit the wall maybe and start
going to church or whatever
so if anything i think church would
probably attract more women
of you know higher programming more [ __ ]
tells and stuff these days
the opposite of what guys were told to
think about it yeah
what are the um field reports that keeps
coming up on my private men's group is
guys will take a screenshot of like a
tinder profile or
or bumble profile or something like that
and it's a picture of a girl that says
i don't know something about like you
know only looking for a good christian
man but you got a girl here that's a
single mother she's got 72 tattoos all
over her body
she's got a low cut top showing off her
tits like come on
like at what point did you find jesus
was it last week because you wanted to
find beta bucks
well okay
this is what
irritates me about the
um manosphere is they act like
that's the majority but i've been to a
lot of different churches i
i do not know a lot of single moms in
church right well i think i've noticed
this that
a lot of women the church is kind of
interesting because there are two groups
that kind of find the church late in
life
they're generally guys who get locked up
and women who have been [ __ ] for 15 20
years
they they overwhelmingly go into church
and the brilliant thing i noticed
in one of the churches i went to while
growing up was all the women gave off
this really pious vibe
and the pastor was really really vocal
about
not sleeping around adultery etc
and he was the reason i coined what i
call the brimstone preacher principle
because this guy he would stand on the
pulpit on sunday
and talk about not uh cheating and then
he would be [ __ ]
half of the married women in the
congregation on a rotation
right right that does happen a lot and
this is what you have to realize when
you get more power
like that comes with people that will
abuse power and any hierarchy like you
see it in
businesses you see it in even the office
of the presidency of course you're gonna
see it in a church
writing the the fourth book it's no
secret the fourth book is about the
religion
religion and the red pill and this is
part of what i got into
um one thing i'm i'm really kind of
getting sick from
uh is listening to more tradcon guys or
you know quote-unquote neo-masculine guy
saying well you need to go find a
traditional
quality brother you just muted yourself
all
right
so where do you find that quote-unquote
quality woman well you've got to go to
church or you've got to go find her in a
bookstore
or you got to go find her somewhere
where [ __ ] don't go right which of
course i guess they're all reading in
barnes and noble or some [ __ ] like that
the church is one of those places i
think you need to understand the
dynamics of why women go to church in
the first place
just as donovan was saying you know
women
go to church when they want to get right
with god when they're in their epiphany
phase and they're
i would say i would argue that the women
who are in church that you would want to
get with in any way
either were raised in that church or
else they came
back to that church after their party
years because they
now they want to get with the beta bucks
guys and now they want to get right with
god and now they want to do things the
right way
and now well you know i'm gonna i'm
looking for a guy who's a good provider
and it's not like one of these bad boys
that that
impregnated me and i've got two kids by
right now uh i need a guy who's got
you know who's who's also a strong man
of god who's going
um i swear nobody in the manosphere is
going
to so i get nervous talking like this
um there are women
that make decisions
and see the consequences of those
decisions and regret them later like
i know a girl in my church that
she like had six months or a year where
she was just like nuts
saw that she was crazy went back to the
church or saw like that it was crazy
saw the repercussions that happened went
back to the church she ended up waiting
until she was married with
her husband and a lot of people would
call her husband a beta male but like
they have one of the happiest marriages
that i've seen they have two kids
and it's just i guess sad that the man
of sphere would like
look down on their marriage be just
because
like i don't know she made mistakes at
one point like people can't make
mistakes going to
uh take care of me and my kids and man
up and be a chivalrous
you know knight in shining armor to come
and get me but he's got to also love
jesus
because real men love jesus right and so
with that i think that's the appeal for
women to go back to church because it's
sort of this symbolic
uh you know thing for them to go back to
church to prove that you know they're
getting right and the other thing is if
you look at christianity
and in particular it's based on
forgiveness so
when women have become you know they've
got like two kids and they've got
tats and whatever else and they've lived
this party party girl lifestyle for most
of their 20s
they're looking for that forgiveness
they want to be absolved of the
indiscretions that they took when they
were you know when they had
a better capacity to explore their
hypergamous natures
well now they don't now i'm 29 and
between 29 and 31 years old
i'm about to hit the wall i'm in my
epiphany phase and i need
i need a guy because i'm getting right
with god and he's forgiven me
and i'm starting all over again i mean
even to the point where some of these
women are saying
yeah i'm a born-again virgin i mean that
is actually a thing
listen so i i'm just telling you like
right now
women is just what rich was saying women
are women no matter whether you find
them in church or you find them that's
why
people yeah that's a thing i've heard of
that people really take me to task on
this they say
they say i'm looking for a quality woman
you know a quality woman is x y and z
i'm like every guy
who married i mean i i hate to pick on
you rich but i'm sure that your ex-wife
you said
this is a quality woman and what did you
call her
after the divorce proceedings were over
yep i can't believe that [ __ ] did this
to me
and i'll tell you that that's the thing
is women are women
they have the same potential to go feral
whether they're christian
or they're a biker chick from hell okay
i mean it's the same hypergamy is
hypergaming well
obviously every person has the potential
to do
like this they act like this is such uh
i hate i hate talking like this because
i know the manager i'll be like oh she's
triggered
i'm not triggered i just what i see is
that they have
no like room for women to make mistakes
i'm not talking about girls that like
sledded up for like 10 years and did
that stuff for like decades
but they're just
very and like they're talking about how
the capacity for
um trying to think of how to say this
like
the capacity for like
men isn't the same like men that are
able to like hook up with a lot of girls
tend to do the same thing
so i don't know just my two cents sorry
i'm a little like
tired today no matter what the dem what
demographic you're
you're looking at um and then just to
finish off here uh this is actually
going to be a part of my book
and a book four um where i go into
the aspects of why women get into
religion to begin with all right so
donovan you want to wind it down
yeah this is real quick girls use
religion
and celibacy or or i'm a born-again
virgin
they use this to artificially inflate
the cost of their affection
okay women know they ain't [ __ ] right
like they
know this so they're out there slutting
it up
guys know their [ __ ] guys know that you
know she's got tattoos she's got a baby
daddy this and that and the other
i always go to the extreme like i do not
know
women in the church that are the same so
she thinks to herself what can i do to
separate myself from other women what
can i do
to raise the price what can i do to make
men work harder for me in other words
what can i do to get more out of men
i'm a born-again virgin or yes i'm you
know i'm in the church
they do this because they think that
this makes them a higher quality woman
oh you're a christian oh you must be
high quality so let me treat you
with chivalry let me shower you with
gifts because you're not like the other
girls
oh you've been celibate for three years
right oh well then that must mean that
that must mean your vagina is more
valuable let me
let me shower you with gifts and
attention because i'm gonna treat you
just like a virgin oh
yes you you've been celibate for three
years so let me treat you like someone
who hasn't had sex in three years
like this is what they do they they they
make these declarations to
to artificially inflate the cost of
their attention
and that image but and this is what
i really wish like the man of spirit
like some women genuinely just make
mistakes and regret them
it's not all just like i'm trying to
inflate the cause
like i don't even know what he's talking
about but inflate like my value it's
saying like i made these mistakes i
regret them i want to do better in the
future
and i don't know the manosphere does not
have a lot of like
forgiveness i guess for that but i'm
sure it's because a lot of men got into
relationships with women that they
thought were quality and then ended up
screwing them over so i could see why
[ __ ]
fits in to the beta male blue pill hope
for the future okay when a guy gets to
be
29 28 29 and this woman shows up and
she's
she's got tats she looks kind of hot
kind of like those girls that he wanted
to get with when he was 20 but
no she's like those girls only better
because she's a christian
right and now i've been you know uh
socking my money away i've got my degree
i've made partner in the attorneys i
whatever i've i've done everything by
the old set of books and the old rule
set now here comes this girl and she
says you know what
uh i'm not like those other girls
because i'm a christian
she fits in to that guy's blue pill
ideal and he thinks he he thinks he's
finally hit pay dirt
i've got this one story we're just real
quick this is one but she's not
actually is what they're saying yeah i'm
not going to lie there's a lot of
disingenuous like christians
like that's that's a guy who was i think
there's this one was one woman who was
like an
ex-porn star who found jesus and now
that's like her shtick
and so she she's like now they pastor's
wife
because uh she's got that's her story
that's her testimony right she's got
past all of that and and of course you
know i will tell you right now she
became a pastor
yeah maybe she was a pastor as well she
becomes
the highest smv [ __ ]
in that church right there she she puts
every other woman to shame
doesn't matter what the you know you
know what that other chick has been
doing for the rest of her life
because she used to be a porn star and
and but she's a porn star for jesus now
and she's okay with it
and she's forgiven and she's this ideal
she's this ideal sexuality
but she is also this you know she's also
this christian so she fits into that
that kind of uh celebrity for those
um i definitely understand where they're
coming from and i think like
a lot of men are frustrated because they
think they're like
dating a type of woman and they're not
actually dating that type of woman
um i will say that like women are put in
a position where they're forced to like
make make decisions
younger than men are and they're given
like attention a lot younger than men
are and they're not
in my opinion like as wise as it could
be
i personally have seen like a lot of i'm
not going to pretend that i know like
all the stats about everything i don't
but i have seen a lot of girls like do
things and like genuinely
regret those mistakes so um
let me know in the comments if you guys
agree or you disagree with me
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification
bell i'll talk to you guys next time